to support and defend the Constitution
and to protect the American people this
week the House passed nine bills to
support veterans protecting their health
benefits financial security and taking
actions to end the crisis for military
families facing tax hikes under the GOP
tax scam with the kiddie tax suffered so
much are now forced to pay thousands of
dollars in taxes on their benefits they
cannot be forced to sacrifice twice as
Democrats to take action to protect
military families we also hard at work
to protect our workers in stark contrast
to the Republicans special interest
agenda today in the same legislation
that contains the kiddie tax Act that's
to tax fix to fix what the Republicans
did in their tax scam we're passing the
secure act we're passing strong measures
to help workers have a secure retirement
and yesterday congressman Watters
consumer first act reversing the
administration's destruction of the
consumer Bureau which the super bill
returned nearly 12 billion dollars to 30
million seniors service members and
veterans before being gutted by the
Trump administration also to honor
we're hoping to have a disaster
supplemental they'll pass before we
leave for the district world period that
was our hope that's what we've been
working on we small hours of the night
last night however we have sent
legislation bipartisan legislation
passed in the house to the Senate it
would be helpful for those in the
disaster-stricken areas if the Senate
would just pass the bill and bills and
send it on to the president we passed a
bill a while back months ago and then in
light of other disasters that occurred
in the spring we then May 10th passed
another bill that expanded of the areas
that were affected that's sitting over
at the Senate they could well just pass
it and send it to the president that
would send up such a beautiful message
to those areas that are affected and
continue to be effect you see what's
happening in Missouri as we gather here
the what's the problem is is that the
Trump administration has put in
conditions for border funding they're
just totally unacceptable really don't
have anything to do with what we're
trying to do for disaster assistance and
we have not been able to find common
ground we understand our responsibility
to protect our border but what they're
doing is just not right and it's
important to note that in the ten years
before this not a single child died in
the custody custody of the Border Patrol
border now six children have died in the
last several months six children have
died in last several months further
honoring oath means honoring our
constitutional responsibility conduct
oversight of the president and the Trump
administration that responsibility has
been resoundingly affirmed again and
again making absolutely clear that the
house has the responsibility to follow
the facts uncovered the truth for the
American people
yesterday's Deutsche Bank ruling
concluded and I quote put simply the
power of Congress to conduct
investigations is inherent in the
legislative process
and in the majors case that would be on
Monday the judge declared there can be
little doubt that Congress interest in
the accuracy of the president's
financial disclosures falls within the
legislative sphere but the president's
priority is his personal and political
interest not the public interest
yesterday as you know Democrats went to
the White House prepared to offer the
president the opportunity to launch an
historic infrastructure initiative we
had met three weeks before the idea that
we and was a good positive meeting about
how we build the infrastructure of our
country roads bridges mass transit
broadband in rural areas and in
underserved urban areas as well water
systems both wastewater and safe clean
drinking water infrastructure for our
satellites so that our technology works
here for all of these things we were
optimistic we also were hoping for
housing and school construction as a
further part of the conversation but the
question is how was it paid for and the
president was going to put the plan was
as we agree that they were meeting three
weeks ago the president was to present
his proposals at yesterday's meeting
well everyone they started making
sending signals that he may not be he
might not be ready or interested the
night before he sent us a letter to
Chuck Schumer and to me saying that he
doesn't want to do infrastructure until
we do the us-mexico Canada if that's not
the accurate some people call it after
NAFTA some call it NAFTA 2.0 but anyway
that trade agreement and that was a
strange juxtaposition but nonetheless of
the next day you know what happened I
think what happened he says it's because
of cover-up and I know that that strikes
a chord with him and he's afraid of
cover-up but afraid of being accused of
cover-up but I really think that what he
knew the the one court decision was
getting into a territory that he did not
want touched and they did not allow the
Moller report another investigation go
into president's personal finances
so Mazur was a setback for him and then
he must have known the Deutsche Bank
decision would be consistent but in any
event to inoculated against its a
presentation
he pulled a stunt now my truly believe
that the president has a bag of tricks
in the White House has a bag of tricks
that they saved for certain occasions
they don't necessarily apply to the
occasion but they're a distraction which
is his his master of distraction we will
all agree on that that's something he
does well to distract from problems that
he has he changes it tries to change the
subject and while he tried to say it's
because I said cover up we've been
saying cover up for a while and our 9
o'clock meeting was a meeting we have
anyway so it had nothing to do with him
but I think what really got to him was
that these court cases and the fact
there's a house Democratic caucus is not
on a path to impeachment and that's
where he wants us to be and when he saw
that that was not happening
that again with the cover-up what she
understands is true just struck a chord
so it was really sad because as I said
to some of you yesterday Thomas
Jefferson one of our third President had
the first infrastructure initiative he
tasked go out galitsin who was his
secretary of the Treasury and I said
that to the secretary of the Treasury
yesterday and after the president left
out of the room then he tasked his
secretary of the Treasury to put
together a big infrastructure plan to
follow the Lewis and Clark expedition
the Louisiana Purchase to build into the
infrastructure of America cumberland
rove erie canal things like that that's
so important to our country in terms of
commerce and mobility and the rest and
then a hundred years later 100 years
later Teddy Roosevelt he initiated his
his infrastructure plan which was green
the establishment of the National Park
Service later in the century president
Eisen
put forth the interstate highway
proposal was very bipartisan leader in
the Senate was Lyndon Johnson in the
house Sam Rayburn
and the President of the United States a
Republican President Eisenhower working
together to make pass that for the good
of the country and its purpose under
President President Eisenhower was that
it would unify America with a defense
issue so what we're talking about now
infrastructure a president he says I
word I thought he was talking about
infrastructure roads bridges met mass
transit I said some of these things
already and I thought we could give him
the opportunity to make a historic
contribution to the safety because it's
a safety measure Commerc it's about
commerce it's about safety it's about
mobility product to market and the rest
it's about clean air clean water it's
about a better future for our country
much-needed billions of trillions of
dollars in deficit in terms of low or no
maintenance that we haven't afford its
never been buy and it's never been
partisan we all wanted to be partisan
now but I can only think that he wasn't
up to the task of figuring out the
difficult choices of how to cover the
cost of what the important
infrastructure legislation that we had
talked about three weeks before so so
but the president again stormed out and
I think what first pound the table walk
out the door right next time have the TV
cameras in there while I have my say
that didn't work for him either and now
this time another tenth temper tantrum
again I pray for the President of the
United States I wish that his family or
his administration or his staff would
have an intervention for the good of the
country yes ma'am
would you be prepared to change IM and
that well being of the united states of
america like cover-up or to not perhaps
provoke him would you be open to that
well you have bought into his excuse no
that was not a reason that he did that
yesterday that was an excuse for him to
do that and with all due respect to your
question i am do not intend not to honor
my oath of office nor do my colleagues
and the house of representatives to
honor our oath of office to protect and
defend the constitution which has a
system of checks and balances separation
of power in it and again is the question
of the american people understanding
that what he is doing is an assault on
the Constitution of the United States we
can walk and chew gum at the same time I
hope he can to let me be really very
clear the president's behavior in terms
of his obstruction of justice the things
that he is doing is very clear it's in
plain sight it cannot be denied ignoring
subpoenas obstruction of justice
yes these could be impeachable offenses
but I intend not if we're we're the fact
there are three things you might
understand it better if you remember
these three things we want to follow the
facts to get the truth to the American
people with a recognition to that no one
is above the wall and three that the
president is engaged in a cover-up and
that is what my statement is how do we
deal with it is a decision that our
caucus makes our caucus is very much
saying whatever we do we need to be
ready
we do it and I do think that impeachment
is a very divisive place to go in our
country and what we can get the facts of
American people through our
investigation it may take us to a place
that is unavoidable in terms of
engagement or not but we're not at that
place
madam Speaker yes of course I mean you
know we're dealing with a situation that
is becoming more predictable but I do
think that we have a responsibility to
try to find common ground it's funny us
out question Casey Casey because
yesterday I was going to start the
meeting in terms of of course putting it
in historical perspective as I have done
here but also today we're very busy
people the leaders in the Congress
especially the President of the United
States I think and a meeting between the
leaders of the Congress and the
president is an historic meeting this is
not a casual coming together of
Democrats and Republicans is this is a
historic meeting it's the leadership of
the legislative branch the first branch
of government and the President of the
United States so let's make it count for
something let's really make it count for
something by dint of preparation by dint
of respect for each other's views
understanding that we'll have to yield
on points to get the results for the
American people but he obviously did not
was not prepared by dint of preparation
he was not prepared and so we used some
excuse to go out the door and I was
asking for his irresponsible behavior
because we're pointing out the truth
America madam Speaker madam Speaker I'm
not gonna talk about her I responded as
the Speaker of the House to the
President of the United States other
conversations people want to have among
themselves is up to them yes
why don't you go ask that president
question of the President of the United
States we have always been responsible
let's do their own devices our
appropriators can all wait I'm an
appropriate forged in that culture
intelligence and appropriations and in
those days they were not really partisan
arenas so the foreign Cleon disaster
assistance we could have gotten there
left to their own devices of the
appropriators until the white house
intervened so that we we will have to
pass up the appropriations bills and we
will and hopefully we will do them in a
very timely fashion the debt ceiling
will have to be lifted and that's a
matter of just a conversation that we're
having on the debt ceiling we're not
saying as the president said if you
don't if you don't stop investigating me
if you don't stop honoring your oath of
office I can't work with you
that's basically what he's saying maybe
he wants to take a leave of absence
I don't know but on the other hand we
really we understand where our
responsibilities are we're fully
prepared to go forward it really will be
up to them to what we want to do what we
have to do that it's right for the
American people respectful with all the
equities that have to be weighed madam
Speaker madam Speaker madam Speaker
okay the one intervention oh I thought
you said statutory information that
would be good article 25 troublemaker
that's a good idea I'm glad you
suggested I'll take it up with my caucus
not that they haven't been thinking
about it but your support will be
important to them oh yes there's no
question the White House is just crying
out for impeach that's why he flipped
yesterday because he was hoping because
he was somehow or other you all have a
story that isn't real I mean you want to
believe that there's all this unease in
our caucus that simply isn't the truth
we have respect for the diversity of
opinion in our caucus and I say to the
caucus our diversity is our strength our
unity is our power and we have unity in
our caucus and so when he saw that see
he's saying oh you called that meeting
at nine o'clock no we have meaning mr.
president it's not about you but it is
about whatever is current at that time
and and so somehow or other you're you
keep perpetuating this story I don't
know why because it isn't factual but
nonetheless that was what disappointed
him because he didn't see this rush to
impeachment coming out of our caucus in
our nine o'clock meeting which he
thought was called specifically for him
and then in Vice up to his family and
his and his admission his cabinet and
his staff in the White House this is not
behavior that is rises to the dignity of
the office of President of the United
States but having said that as I said I
actually ardently pray for the president
because we need I don't know sometimes
when we were talking to him he's he
agrees and then I said one time who's in
charge here because you agree and then
all of a sudden
something changes what goes on there
who's in charge and he says he's in
charge and I suspect that he may be and
I suspect he may be even more since
yesterday because I don't think that any
responsible assistant to the President
of the United States would've advised
him to do what he did yesterday that's
it